crise politique sur fond de crise
sanitaire la tunisie toujours dans une
situation délicate le président queille
sayyed a décidé de reprendre les rênes
du pays la semaine dernière
l'une de ses premières préoccupations
semblent être l'accélération de la
vaccination
grâce notamment à l'aide internationale
qui continue d'affluer
les détails avec notre correspondant à
tunis ben hassen chébili la tunisie
plongé dans une crise politique qui
s'approfondit depuis des mois a subi une
vague meurtrière
tu coronavirus depuis le jet des
activités du parlement le limogeage du
premier ministre le président qui
détient actuellement des pouvoirs très
étendus a vivement critiqué la gestion
catastrophique de l'épidémie par le
gouvernement et les parlementaires plus
d'une année et passer les réunions se
sont succédé mais les gens sont
hospitalisés et meurent par centaines
chaque jour sans oublier la
multiplication des contaminations fasse
une propagation meurtrière du variant
delta au manque de vaccins et d'oxygène
dans les hôpitaux à bout de souffle
la tunisie enregistre l'un des pires
taux de mortalité au monde avec près de
20 mille décès depuis le début de la
pandémie pour une population de 12
millions d'habitants mais depuis l'aide
internationale afflue dans ce petit pays
dont l'économie et fragilisé c'est la
france les états unis l'algérie ont
entre autres fait preuve de solidarité
tout comme l'italie qui vient de livrer
la tunisie 1,5 million de doses de
vaccins une aide précieuse réceptionné
par le président lui-même
kaïs ayed a même déclaré qu'il
souhaitait fixer une date à laquelle
près de 3 millions de tunisiens
devraient être vaccinés grâce à cette
vague de solidarité internationale le
pays espère immunisés environ 50 % de sa
population d'ici la mi octobre